Growing up in Mississippi,
my family never talked about money,
but I could infer how much people had
by pattern keeping at Christmas time.
My uncle Chip was always good for money,
an absolute delight.
JCPenney's, here I come.
(Laughter)
Mama Adele would always
give us apples, oranges,
butterscotch candy, in a brown paper bag.
It was a gift given with love
and it meant a lot
coming from the matriarch of our family.
Now my parents,
my parents would make sure my twin and I
were fresh in the latest fashions.
Girbaud jeans, Starter jackets.
Looking good made us feel rich,
even if we weren't.
So it was interesting
because I remember
having a myriad of conversations
about prison reform, the education system,
voter rights,
but a candid conversation about money,
it never happened.
When I went to graduate school,
my world expanded.
Hearing my friends talk
about their overseas adventures
made me envious.
I didn't even have a passport at the time.
When I got my first job
post graduate school,
I was making 70,000 dollars.
I was rich.
But that shopping spree at JCPenney's
was no longer going to scratch that itch.
I needed to do whatever I could
to be legit wealthy.
I think that’s why one of the many
Oprah Winfrey episodes that I watched
[in] the early 2000s stood out to me.
On this particular episode,
Suze Orman was the guest.
And for those of you who don't know,
Suze is an American author
and financial advisor,
and she has the most perfect
white teeth I've ever seen.
(Laughter)
Well, Suze was talking about 401(k)s,
and I got the basic gist
of what she was saying.
Save a little money now,
have a lot of money in the future.
Sounded great, amazing, sign me up.
So I went to meet a wealth advisor,
somebody I met off the internet.
I just knew that this random person
was going to unlock some magical room
and give me all the tricks
I needed to be wealthy.
I mean big house, fancy cars,
luxurious vacation.
I was excited until I wasn't.
The nondescript building in a strip mall
did not boost my confidence
that this was how the wealthy
managed their affairs.
(Laughter)
I was placed in a small white waiting room
and I stayed there
for what felt like forever.
Finally, a man came in
who could not even bother
to learn the correct
pronunciation of my name
and asked me what my goals
were for the future.
OK, I'm excited again.
I know the answer to this.
Number one, I would like to retire
comfortably by the age of 60.
Number two, I would like to be
able to take care of my mom.
His response,
"I don't know why taking care
of your mother is your responsibility."
He then went on to speak
in some financial jargon
I could not understand.
The entire interaction took me so aback
that I vowed to share the bare minimum
the rest of the meeting.
I could not figure out what I was missing,
but it made me question everything.
Maybe I did not know what wealth was.
Maybe wealth was not intended
for people like me.
Maybe I was reaching for too much.
So I find it funny, or maybe serendipitous
that I think about cash
and wealth all the time now.
For the last ten years,
I've led an organization
in Jackson, Mississippi,
that takes a radically community-driven
approach to supporting families,
mainly Black women,
that live in federally subsidized
affordable housing.
Our programs are strategic and holistic.
A few years ago,
we became concerned that we were not
moving the needle on poverty.
So we went to the women that we work with
and we said, "What are we missing?"
The answers were all different,
but the underlying problem was the same.
The problem was the lack of cash.
No money for pizza on a Friday night
was causing stress.
Unexpected car repairs
were leading to unemployment
because people could not
get to and from work.
So we began to research
how do you give money,
not another program, to people
experiencing poverty?
In 2018, we launched
the Magnolia Mother's Trust,
this country's first modern
guaranteed-income program,
and the first in the world
to center its efforts on Black women.
(Cheers)
Thank you.
(Applause)
Quickly, for the uninitiated,
a guaranteed income
is a specific amount of money
given to a specific population
over a set amount of time.
It's typically funded
by private philanthropy
or in some instances, the public sector.
It's not a new idea.
Jenny Tillman, a mom and welfare activist,
called for a guaranteed income
way back in 1972,
and even Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
and President Nixon indicated
that a guaranteed income
could help solve for poverty.
It's not a new idea,
but like I said, we are pioneers
and our efforts are working.
We provide 1,000 dollars a month
for 12 months to Black mothers.
And our goal is simple:
to provide these women
with the breathing room they need
by giving them the financial
resources they need
to dream a little bigger.
We provide --
Thank you.
(Applause)
We provide 1,000 dollars
a month for 12 months,
and we have proven that 12,000 dollars
is a life-altering amount of money.
Yes, it allows you to take care
of the practical needs,
like getting that car repaired,
but it also allows you
to shift your reality.
Literally, shift your reality
from scarcity to abundance,
from tunneling to imagination,
from scraping by to genuine opportunity.
There are over 100
guaranteed income programs
currently being implemented
in this country,
and many were inspired by what we started
in Jackson, Mississippi, of all places.
Black women have ushered in
a movement and it has been beautiful,
but it is just the start.
Over the last few years,
as I have watched more and more moms
move towards income stability,
I have listened as they
have began to dream
about a life free of economic stress.
I have watched as they began
to dream about wealth.
Now, I understand that the most
basic definition of wealth
is what you own, minus what you owe.
And I also know we typically define it
as having big cars,
luxurious vacations,
one-upping our neighbor on this
never-ending ladder of economic success.
But for many women,
particularly women of color,
who do not have access
or the ability to earn a living wage
because of pay inequity,
that definition
is meaningless or inadequate.
Lord knows that we must solve
for the racial wealth gap,
and it is going to take
radical imagination
and a reinvention of big systems.
But until then,
people cannot be gaslit into believing
that their definition of wealth
is invalid or less important.
(Applause)
Thank you.
Bell Hooks once wrote,
"Definitions are a vital starting point
to the imagination.
What one cannot imagine
cannot come into being."
One day I was having
a conversation with Coco,
a mom within the Magnolia Mother's Trust,
and I asked her, "What is wealth to you?"
Without skipping a beat, she said,
"If anything were to happen to me,
my family would have the money
to cover my burial expenses."
Asking more and more women
the same question,
I have come to learn
that wealth is dignified funerals,
the privilege of privacy,
the ability to complete school,
own a business,
or the thrill of being
the extravagant auntie.
All of these are definitions
of wealth to them.
Wealth is about a sense of agency,
a sense of freedom,
the collective well-being of the whole.
It is not an individual
pathological pursuit.
For too long, we have allowed
financial institutions
to define wealth and the process
by which we build it.
I have never had a mother say to me,
wealth is having stocks and bonds,
equity in her home,
or even a retirement account.
Instead, they dream about what a life
of ease and care would look like.
Another case in point.
I was having a conversation
with a mom I work with,
and I asked if she had
six months’ worth of savings
to cover an emergency.
She started laughing.
She could not even see herself
in the equation that I was offering.
She said that "Before
the Magnolia Mothers Trust,
I didn’t even have a savings account,
let alone one month’s worth of savings.”
I said, "OK, let me
ask the question differently.
What is wealth to you?"
She said, "Oh, that's easy.
All of my bills paid every month
with a little left over
for anything extra."
She knew exactly what she needed.
Our narrow definition
simply did not address her needs.
Hearing these responses,
time and time again,
I began to realize
that we have to redefine wealth,
and we actually can redefine wealth.
And a way we do that
is by listening to others
and then by being brave enough
to listen to ourselves.
So of course, y'all,
I had to ask myself, what is wealth?
And I will admit to each of you all
because we're best friends now --
(Laughter)
That when I first asked myself
this question, I started crying.
I realized that for over 20 years,
I had been holding on to a definition
that was not written for me,
nor did it mirror my desires.
I never wanted that big house
backed up against the lake.
I simply wanted what
it represented in my mind:
My ability to gather my people,
to nourish them, to spoil them,
to make sure that we were
protected and cared for
before we go out into the world
doing the hard work of caring for others.
Please hear my words.
I am not saying that women experiencing
poverty simply need space to dream.
If you all walk out
of this theater with that,
I am going to be very unhappy.
(Laughter)
What I am saying
is that the space to dream mixed with cash
can lead to transformation
that can lead to true wealth.
It is my belief that we,
all of us in this room,
are made less [wealthy]
by virtue of tolerating a country
where anyone has to prove their worth.
We may have 500 different
definitions of wealth,
but we can all agree that we are all
degraded by normalizing immoral inequity.
After all these years, I have finally --
(Applause)
After all of these years,
I have finally accomplished
what I set out to achieve
all those years ago
with that random wealth advisor.
I am emboldened and empowered
to manage my wealth
and no, I don't mean money.
I mean, I am a loving daughter,
I am a mom who takes
their boys on vacation
and you best believe
I am an extravagant auntie.
(Laughter)
We have a poverty of imagination
about what makes you wealthy.
I mean the things that people say
about you at your funeral.
I mean legacy.
But here's the thing.
From where I sit, we can offer
that kind of wealth to everyone.
And yes, I am going to play
on the word here,
I can guarantee it,
if we are simply willing to understand
that a small financial investment
can change someone's life,
giving them the flexibility,
breathing room and space
to define and build wealth
on their own terms.
And that may be wealth defined by equity,
love, honor and delight.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)